i need a few more volunteers andy will
you be iceland the bad guys for mighty
ducks too don't think so okay how about
japan the bad guys from karate kid too
even worse how about germany
they've never been the bad guys why
don't you be finland okay okay thanks a
lot
i just traded finland's military to
kenya
for 50 lions
that's pretty good right
yeah okay
but also militaries are pretty good at
protecting countries but so are lions
and you don't have to pay them these
kids are idiots uh i've just traded all
of finland's boring stuff for every
other country's lions
i definitely have more lions than any
other country in the whole world right
now i have no idea what's going on but
if that ends up meaning something in
this game
i'd say i'm sad
hey jakey the place on the corner is
serving lemonade and you get to keep the
jar it's pretty cool
yes
that's very cool scully
will you excuse me just one moment oh
sure guys guys guys
scully has a mason jar full of lemonade
you called us in here to tell us that no
i called you in here to change your
lives before you see a mere five minutes
ago hitchcock introduced me to his new
goldfish who lives in oh an identical
mason jar oh this isn't gonna end well
there are two possible outcomes and
we're gonna bet on which one happens
first so will hitchcock put fish food in
scully's lemonade or will skelly drink
hitchcock's goldfish now you would think
that putting fish food into lemonade
hitchcock just drank his own fish what
no
squad we missed scully's birthday and it
was a big one i told them i was in
ecuador i think they bought it we got to
make it up to them let's give them cash
everyone put in 20 each uh yes i'll
cover you hey scully huh
we're sorry that we missed your party
oh don't worry about it you all have
stuff to do yes the capital of ecuador
is quito oh anyway
happy birthday from all of us thanks
guys you're you're the best ever happy
birthday
i can't believe it the fake birthday
worked
you're a genius we're both geniuses
thump jack that was my thumbtack look we
got it
wow we got it
oscar wait i think the victory would be
more meaningful if aaron puts the last
word in herself
yes pam yes most definitely yes yes no
although i must say
i will have apoplexy
if you lose
do you understand apoplexy is what i
will have
apoplexy yes
oscar
i played ape
thank you
dwight
all done
disposable cameras are fun although it
does seem wasteful and you don't ever
get to see your pictures
if it's an important event that you want
to remember i recommend using a real
camera but i don't care if i forget
today
how's it going i'm bobby newport but you
probably knew that already well mr
newport we made it last i'm leslie knope
ah okey-doke so do you want me to sign
that to ms lope or just nezny what
no i
leslie's fine leslie yeah miss knope is
a candidate for city council i've been
calling your office trying to set up a
debate oh no you guys are wrong i'm
running unopposed i'm pretty sure i'm
running on a pose right
no you're not running unopposed you're
very opposed by me oh terrific i love
meeting people i love it yeah what do
you guys do
we we just told you we're gonna be
running for city council great here have
a bobby bar go ahead my dad made him
okay folks
hey i'm bobby newport i think we scared
him here have a bobby bar my dad made
him the reason why bobby and i are
appearing together is to send the
message that everyone should get out and
vote no matter who they're voting for
that's right another awesome point by
leslie that's why i'm voting for you
[Laughter]
what's so funny you're laughing at your
joke what joe i am voting for you
you're not voting for yourself
leslie you camp over yourself i don't
think pretty sure that's illegal
anything else
look at that thing what is that
don't touch it
let's see i can't figure this thing out
can you help me yeah just hang on a
second bobby ink all over my hands and
the pen thingy came off the chain
i don't get it
you can answer that kel
all right thanks
dunder mifflin this is kevin
please hold while i transfer you
oscar your mom
charles is having kevin cover the phones
for a while
how do i say this diplomatically
i think kevin is doing exactly as well
as anyone might have expected someone
like him to perform in a position like
that
please hold
andy phone call nope stay there
kev i thought we nailed the whole
transfer thing earlier yeah i wrote it
on my hand but then i washed it it is
transfer extension and then transfer
again okay andy get ready transfer here
we go extension
transfer
oh man
it is one three four kevin kevin come on
you are murdering the gnard this is
kevin please hold and i will transfer
you
you're bad at this too don't answer that
call just transfer the damn goal your
call is very important to us
[Applause]
my maid
died me mechanic not speak english but
he know what me mean when me say car no
go and we best friends so me think why
waste time say lot word when few words
do trick
kevin i appreciate what you're trying to
do thank you here we have a word code
the same way we have a dress code and
what we're talking about is
basically the speech equivalent
to just wearing underpants
sometimes words
you know need use
but need need for talk talk
but save time more success does it save
time though because we've been here for
about an hour no me fault
kevin
at most you're saving a microscopic
amount of time
many small time make big time
what are you gonna do with all this time
sea world kevin you can't possibly save
enough time to see the world kevin are
you saying see the world or sea world
sea world
oceans fish
jump okay china no see right there
that's the problem with your method
because i still don't know if you're
saying sea world or see the world and
it's taken a lot of time to explain it
fine
fine i'll talk normally
when me president
they see
they see
alexander didn't see parminion as a
rival he killed him over a dispute about
his son oh no it's boethius all over
again at least you've got one thing
right you do have a rock hard brain
because that's bad everyone knows that a
brain should be soft and wet i wanted to
say that but jake told me not to yeah
because it's gross
there you are
you okay sir i'm fine i've decided to
stop fighting it and lean into the fact
that i'm an idiot look at me playing a
video game oh which one time's crossword
app not a video game well it plays a
little song when you solve it as if
you've just learned a potty
yes yes play me my dances too
you